[موسيقى]
تم تطوير منصة لقاح mrna لأول مرة
في أوائل التسعينيات لاستهداف
الإنفلونزا وفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية من بين أمراض أخرى ،
كل هذا البحث مهد الطريق
للقاح فعال لـ covid19 الآن مع
دفع mrna إلى دائرة الضوء ،
وقد تحدث الكثير من الأشخاص حول إمكاناته.
حيث قد يتطلب الأمر في نهاية المطاف
الطب ،
أطلقت Moderna مؤخرًا
تجربة سريرية للمرحلة الأولى لفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية ،
والتركيز الكبير الآخر الآن هو أن
علماء السرطان يستكشفون
ما إذا كانت تقنية لقاح mrna الجديدة
التي جلبت لنا
لقاحات سرية آمنة وفعالة 19 يمكن استخدامها أيضًا
لإيقاف الخلايا السرطانية عندما  يصلون لأول مرة
ربما يكون من المنطقي إذن أن
العقول التي تقف وراء لقاح pfizer biontech
mrna تعتبر نفسها في الواقع
أطباء السرطان في المقام الأول وقبل كل شيء ، لقد
جلست مؤخرًا لإجراء محادثة افتراضية
مع مؤسسي بايرن تك ، أصلان
توريشي وأوهار شاهين من
مقرهم في ألمانيا
الآن  قبل أن نبدأ في مستقبله ، دعونا
نلقي نظرة على أساسه ،
ما هو بالضبط لقاح mrna
وكيف يعمل هذا
الحمض الريبي النووي المرسال mrna هو
مادة وراثية موجودة في
أجسامنا ترشد خلايانا لإنتاج
بروتينات معينة في حالة covet 19
، يحفز لقاح mrna خلايانا على
صنع بروتين ارتفاع الفيروس التاجي الذي
يحفز جهاز المناعة لدينا على التعرف عليه.
قطعة مهمة من الفيروس وخلق
أجسام مضادة لمكافحته في المستقبل
تقنية mrna لعلاج أمراض مثل
السرطان مختلفة قليلاً تلك اللقاحات
يجب أن تكون مصممة خصيصًا
لعلامات الخلايا السرطانية لكل مريض ولكن
الهدف هو نفس
مساعدة أجسامنا  إنشاء استجابة مناعية
لأداء وظيفتها بشكل أفضل ،
فأنت تعرف الناس
عندما نسمع مصطلح اللقاح الذي
تفكر فيه لمنع المرض ، صحيح
أنه لمنع المرض
عندما نتحدث عنه في السرطان
نتحدث عن علاج ورم موجود
أنت تتحدث عن
علاج السرطان المخصص هنا إذا كان هناك
هدف معين تختار كيف تعرف
أنه خاص بالفعل بهذا السرطان
وليس للخلايا البشرية السليمة في
جسم المريض المعين ،
فإن طريقة اكتشاف ذلك هي المقارنة
مع
الأنسجة الطبيعية للطفرات التي نقوم بها من
خلال المقارنة بخلايا دم المريض
التي
تمثل النظير الطبيعي غير المتحور
وتمثل الأنسجة الطبيعية
و  الأمر المثير هو
أنه في تجربة سريرية ، فإن
الاستجابة المناعية التي يتم إنشاؤها هي
التعرف على الخلية السرطانية ، ولكن ليس
الخطوة العادية ، فإن
biontech لديها حاليًا
تجارب سريرية بشرية لاثنين من أصعب أنواع السرطان لعلاج
سرطان القولون والمستقيم والبنكرياس
يمكن أن تكون mrna مفتاحًا  علاج هذه
الأمراض
[موسيقى]